[Musique]
demain usine de volkswagen à puebla au
mexique va cesser officiellement de
produire la légendaire emblématique
ditto celle que l'on surnomme la
coccinelle
mais en allemagne à la fin des années 30
la beetle est l'une des voitures les
plus vendues au monde en plus d'avoir
été un symbole de la contre-culture dans
les années 60 offert le taux de
l'histoire de ce véhicule là avec notre
invité benoît charette journalistes
automobiles vont ensemble ces charrettes
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on cesse
aujourd'hui la production de l'habitant
je pense qu'on a à peu près fait le tour
du jardin se serait résumé la chose
rapidement pris dire aussi que depuis
quelques années tous les véhicules
utilitaires les véhicules du segment ont
la cote
alors les voitures et volkswagen n'est
pas le seul
on élimine les voitures d'à peu près
tous les grands constructeurs
automobiles en ce moment fort de faire
le ménage dans dernier jm fait le ménage
cette année on voit ces modèles de
disparaître ça veut pas dire qu'on ne le
verra plus jamais volkswagen prépare une
division électrique
oui et peut-être et dont on est dans la
spéculation mais peut-être que sous une
version électrique on pourrait revoir
quelque chose qui ressemblerait à l'ats
beat au bon parce que c'est déjà arrivé
la fin de la production répit tonnes et
la renaissance était revenu se sont
endettés revenant 98 en fait la fin du
modèle original c'est en 2003 on l'avait
déjà eu lieu un chevauchement parce que
les pays d'amérique du sud le mexique en
trop parce que l' usine de puebla nos
produits utilisés beaucoup les anciens
modèles parce qu'ils étaient beaucoup
plus abordables à produire après toutes
ces années là on a remis le modèle en 98
avec beaucoup de nostalgie on avait
ramené l'idée de base on a un petit peu
les rêves masculiniser les lignes d'une
générations subséquentes
je pense que les gens qui avaient à
l'acheter depuis 1998 il avait inscrit
et nostalgie comme étant le temple il
faut dire que c'est une très longue saga
de 1938 admis commencé c'est pas c'est
ferdinand porsche sous le régime
d'adolphe hitler adolf hitler voulait
faire une voiture pour le peuple donc
fawkes wagen c'est la voiture du peuple
et il y avait demandé
un cahier de charges extrêmement serré
on devait faire la voiture en moins d'un
an
ça devait coûter moins de 1000 reich
marks à l'époque l'équivalent d'à peu
près 500 dollars il devait avoir une
consommation mieux que 10 litres aux
cent et on devait pouvoir atteindre un
minimum de 100 km donc si tu as dit en
1938 le c'est extrêmement ambitieux et
ferdinand porsche a répondu à l'appel en
dessinant un véhicule où tout était
pensé à l'économie les gens disent ou
souvent pourquoi il ya un moteur en
arrière ce parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'avs la transmission à mettre parce que
la puissance était directement aux roues
donc on économisait tout était fait pour
l'économie mais c'est finalement modèles
qui ont pas connu beaucoup d'efforts on
en a fabriqué beaucoup de modèles pour
des faits d' utilisation militaire
pendant la guerre c'est vraiment à
partir de l'après guerre dans les années
bon entre 45 et 50 que le modèle
commencé à connaître de l'expansion là
le succès commercial e ce qui est
commercial a fait ce qui le poussait
c'est pour l'époque
il faut bien dire l'on revient de la
guerre des gens pour beaucoup d'argent
veulent quand même se remettre dans leur
vie quotidienne c'est des véhicules qui
étaient très abordable et chose assez
curieuse part c'est un véhicule allemand
qui a beaucoup fonctionné en amérique du
nord qu'un des premiers cabinets des
premiers véhicules étrangers qui a connu
du succès du côté de l'amérique du nord
en 1972
l'habitant le battu le record de ventes
totales du véhicule le plus populaire de
l'époque qui était une modèle t
devant donc les construire devant tout
ce qui se faisait à l'époque et on a
dépassé on atteint le 20 millions de
modèles construits en 1981 bon depuis
quelques modèles qui sont passés devant
la golf la corolla le f-150 évidemment
parce qu'on en prend des quantités
industrielles à chaque année mais ça a
été longtemps le symbole de toute une
époque
le mot clé là dedans c'est longtemps on
parle d'une longévité c'est inédit le ca
existe pas pour d'autres modèles debout
surtout que celui que là-haut jamais
changé de forme il ya des véhicules qui
demeure populaire on les remet à jour on
les modernise la beetle est resté
pratiquement la même pendant 30 ans
[ __ ] plus dans certains endroits etc
c'est ça qui fait qu'on a eu ni con
parce que c'est un véhicule qui est
identifié qui est précis et c'est
peut-être une des raisons qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui va disparaître aussi
parce que comment on charge une bientôt
on ne peut pas vraiment la jeunesse sale
affaire pilote mettre tout le monde en
fait la plupart des gens qui avaient en
acheter un
l'on fait et on arrive à la fin d'une
époque et vous parliez de la renaissance
le nouveau modèle avec les lignes plus
modernes 98 5 ans même fonctionner ça ça
a bien fonctionné au début évidemment on
avait ramené je dirais l'esprit du
véhicule parce que ce n'était plus une
[ __ ] hall le moteur est à l'avastin
chasser différence est beaucoup plus
gros
mais pour les gens qui ont connu le
véhicule mais bon qui était trop jeune à
l'époque qui n'ont conduit mais qui
était pas encore avec un permis de
conduire mais tous ces gens là il y en a
beaucoup qui sont lancés mais là bon
pour les plus jeunes une [ __ ] aussi
moins représentatifs de leur époque
alors l'intérêt au format 10 feuilles
mais ce qui va y avoir quand même un
héritage pour l'industrie le passage la
beatles que ç'a changé quelque chose
pour l'industrie devrait en fait je
dirais que ce que ça a pu changer
c'est l'idée qu'on se fait d'une voiture
européenne
il ya eu après ça dans les années
soixante dix avec la crise du pétrole
les japonais qui sont arrivés la corolla
la civic les petits modèles
mais la beetle a été le premier véhicule
qui pouvait être amusant à conduire qui
était économique puis finalement qui
était compacte parce que dans ces années
là les modèles américains c'était des
modèles de grand format
ouais donc ça l'a amené une culture
différente qui a beaucoup plu aux jeunes
c'est probablement pour ça q ces modèles
ont été si populaire parce que ça brise
est de la tradition que nos parents
grands-parents et pop arrière grands
parents parce que le modèle américain a
toujours été le même et là on a enlevé
avec une autre présentation
officiellement c'est la fin demain mais
sait-on jamais pourrait-on la revoir un
jour on verra ça reste la propriété de
volkswagen à wolfsburg doit faire merci
comme cgc